et pour en parler nous sommes avec
bertrand legrand médecins généralistes
bonsoir et puis sur les enjeux
économiques charles est président de la
carte française est également avec nos
bons soirs alors messieurs je vous
propose de débuter avec la situation
sanitaire on le disait le plan blanc a
donc été déclenché dans les hôpitaux
d'île de france obligeant la
déprogrammation soin de nouvelles villes
en alerte maximale dont lille
alors après cette nouvelle prise de
parole du ministre de la santé bertrand
legrand
vous avez le sentiment d'un gouvernement
qui agit ou alors qu'il subit eh bien ça
fait maintenant plus d'un mois que quand
vous montez à jouer et je vous dis que
la situation se dégrade et qu'un grand
nombre de patients sont actuellement en
augmentation de nombre d'incidents ce je
remarque que comme à chaque comme à la
première vague et comme bien souvent on
écoute les signaux d alerte qu'à partir
du moment où ça arrive à l'hôpital en
réanimation et qu'il est donc déjà trop
tard puisque le changement d'attitude
était adopté il ya quinze jours au
moment où martine aubry notre mère
faisait tout ce qu'il fallait pour
éviter les mesures qu'on aurait bien
besoin aujourd'hui
elle aurait dû il y a quinze jours fork
faire comme à nice à marseille nice a
marre et marseille où une inflexion
positive 1 selon le gouvernement ce sont
ces mesures qui paye
alors on a un problème de communication
avec vous bertrand legrand on va donc
s'intéresser maintenant aux enjeux
économiques avec vous charles bête de
nombreux secteurs professionnels a on le
sait prennent la crise de plein fouet
c'est pour cela que bruno le maire ce
soir s'est exprimé également aux côtés
d'olivier ferrand et cette annonce
l'accès au fonds de solidarité facilités
élargies accessible jusqu'à 10000 euros
s'ils perdent du chiffre d'affaires de
70 % contre 80 % précédemment c'est un
bon ajustement nécessaire charles huet
écouter tout ce qui va dans le sens du
soutien à la survie de nos entreprises
en particulier les plus petites les
commerçants les tpe les pme et tous les
industriels et commerçants français est
positif
dix mille euros ça va pas forcément
permettre à tous de passer noël loin de
là le prêt garanti par l'état c'est une
excellente mesure mais à un moment donné
il faudra quand même les rembourser
aujourd'hui je pense que il faut surtout
le plan de relance globalement est très
intéressant mais est très long terme
c'est de l'investissement c'est des
baisses d'impôts de production c'est des
aides à la relocalisation tout ça est
très positif mais à très court terme il
faut que la consommation et ce dernier
trimestre décisif en matière économique
pour nos entrepreneurs puissent se
passer dans les meilleures conditions
et pour ça il va falloir avoir de bonnes
nouvelles du point de vue sanitaire
idéalement des réouvertures de nos
restaurants et bars sans condition et
peu et j'espère des nouvelles
suffisamment bonne pour pour aussi
permettre la réorganisation de beaucoup
de salons dont dont beaucoup de secteurs
d'activité dépendent je pense en
particulier à l'annulation du salon du
made in france qui est le grand
rendez-vous du made in france qui devait
se tenir les 6 et 20 novembre prochains
et qui malheureusement est tendu et qui
au delà des conséquences pour l'organe
et les organisatrices elle même aura des
conséquences sur tout l'écosystème du
made in france et je crois que voilà on
doit tous agir on peut agir
il va falloir maintenant agir sur la
demande sur la consommation justement
charlotte et ça a plu d'ailleurs
interpellé 1 ce soir ses propos de bruno
le maire qui dit c'est maintenant qu'il
faut investir c'est le bon moment de
créer son entreprise
comment vous comprenez cet appel du
ministre de l'économie ce soir qui peut
apparaître un peu paradoxal finalement
avec la situation s'est un peu de la
méthode coué il a raison il faut des
entrepreneurs il faut de
l'investissement
les périodes de crise sont aussi les
pertes d'opportunités ce qui est certain
c'est que beaucoup d'entreprises ont
besoin de son propre et on buzze de
trésorerie et puis même de se développer
donc évidemment que il faut investir
maintenant plus que jamais parce que
c'est utile à la nation
après c'est vrai que le contexte était
très incertain quant à l'avenir mais en
moins sur des sur un stand ombre de
positionnement sur le made in france en
particulier sur les enjeux d'engagement
d'écologie sur sur le tout ce que tout
ce que le coc vide a changé dans nos
habitudes de consommation sont des
secteurs prometteurs cher le web ce que
vous nous dites finalement c'est que
avec cette crise va elle nous permet
finalement de repenser l'économie
c'est cela mais ça passera par où selon
vous ça passera pas sa part passer
simplement des paroles aux actes
ça fait dix ans que tout le monde y
aspirent que tout le monde en parle de
ces transitions de consommer médine
france de consommer local de réduire son
empreinte carbone
maintenant le sujet c'est de moins
parler de plus agir et on peut tous le
faire à titre personnel à titre
professionnel par exemple ne serait ce
que pour donner un ordre de grandeur le
plan de relocalisation prévu par de
subventions aux usines qui relocalisent
prévue par l'état et d'un montant
inférieur à l'argent distribué chaque
année par les comités d'entreprise
ces comités d'entreprise en fléchant
vers le local et nos pme tpe
cet argent dispose d'un plan de relance
entre leurs mains comme chacun d'entre
vous disposez d'un plan de relance dans
votre portefeuille avec votre carte
bleue
donc maintenant le sujet c'est de ces de
passer des paroles aux actes et de
sortir un petit peu de cette période
anxiogène et de consommer moins mais
mieux après à noël on a tous tendance à
se détendre sur les cadeaux qu'on a à
faire à nos proches et et et il va
falloir maintenant choisir précisément
qui on veut subventionner puisque on a
des commerçants qui ont fermé pendant le
coville
et qui vient de connaître les sur les de
noël successifs les gilets jaunes et les
grèves contre les retraites
un troisième noël avec des restrictions
de sortie de consommation serait tout
simplement mortel pour un tiers des tpe
qui craignent de faire de mettre la clé
sous la porte à la avant la fin de
l'année alors une crise économique on le
sait intimement liée avec la crise
sanitaire bertrand legrand quand charles
madiba il va falloir réouverte réouvrir
les bars et les restaurants assez
rapidement puisque l'économie et est en
grand danger on viens de l'entendre
qu'est ce que vous dites vous en tant
que médecin aujourd'hui c'est pas le
moment vous appelez à la
responsabilisation des français comme
l'a fait olivier ferrand oui
effectivement je suis dit j'ai un
deuxième j'ai un deuxième sont
extrêmement compliqué de vous répondre
il faut absolument réussir à
reconstruire mais l'ouverture ne doit
surtout pas se faire au profit d'une
multiplication des contacts sociaux
aujourd'hui les hôpitaux comme les
médecins libéraux sont face à un afflux
qui est très important et nous
n'arrivons plus à prendre en charge
l'ensemble des patients qui vont de
toute façon terminé à l'hôpital pour une
partie d'entre eux donc réellement ce
qu'on a besoin c'est surtout d'une
diminution des interactions sociales et
on doit prendre ces mesures le plus vite
possible car quinze jours après c'est
beaucoup trop tard ça finit à l'hôpital
parce que en tant que médecin libéral
vous très concrètement vous constaté un
afflux massif ces derniers temps ces
derniers jours de nouveaux malades
oui on est on est vraiment sur quelque
chose de très difficile
j'ai plus de 90 acte par jour et
effectivement c'est très compliqué vous
imaginez bien que un cabinet de médecine
générale avec deux médecins qui fait
autant dur jeu d'entrée aux yeux que les
urgences de mon territoire
c'est quelque chose de qui est
impossible à faire ça fait un mois
contre san nas et la sirène d'alarmé
aujourd'hui on le mesure
on voit que ça commence à se transférer
à l'hôpital on a eu la période où on
nous a dit benoîtement qu'il fallait que
les jeunes se contaminent et aujourd'hui
on voit bien que les jeunes contaminés
ont renvoyé les plus âgées à l'hôpital
c'est extrêmement gênant il faut de
lutter contre la contamination c'est la
seule chose
brest est ce que le lien entre les
médecins du secteur privé et les
médecins du secteur libéral pourrait
être penser différemment selon vous
justement pour faire face à cet afflux
de malades
je suis vraiment dans les oreilles et du
coup j'ai dû beaucoup plus de mal à vous
répondre
il ya une grosse différence entre le
médecin libéral et le médecin
hospitalier car le arrive non au moins
quinze jours après et ne voient qu'une
petite partie une fraction infime des
personnes que nous voyons et nous sommes
en fait une vigie bien en amont et bien
mal récompensée puisque je vous rappelle
que actuellement dans les négociations
conventionnelles que nous avons il n'ya
que 300 millions sur la table alors même
que l'hôpital va avoir une enveloppe de
huit milliards d'euros
on a vraiment le sentiment d'avoir été
abandonnés est ravi par le gouvernement
alors même qu'on fait la plus grosse
partie du travail à savoir lutter contre
la propagation de l'épidémie car le
maître peut être un mot on entend ces
médecins effectivement se sentir
abandonnés avec pas suffisamment de
moyens
est-ce que effectivement vous avez le
sentiment que le gouvernement met plus
de moyens sur l'économie est moins dans
le secteur hospitalier aujourd'hui
non je je je ne jugerai pas de ça
évidemment que la lutte contre la
propagation du virus est prioritaire que
la santé prioritaires après c'est
toujours un sujet d'équilibrage
l' équilibre tout simplement par rapport
à par rapport à la santé économique
aussi puisque le chômage la
désindustrialisation tout ça génère
aussi un somme de pathologies parfois
très graves et mortels h
et puis nos modèles sociaux notre
sécurité sociale nos hôpitaux nos
soignants sont aussi financé par des
cotisations qui sont assis sur les
salaires à force de chômage partiel et
de fermetures d'usinés délocalisations
et de et de faillite
bon on aura encore moins pour financer
l'hôpital et la santé donc il faut bien
voilà mesurer et est très équilibré dans
sedan dans dans ce principe de
précaution qui à force d'être excessif
pourrait nous faire mourir en excellente
santé mais à mourir quand même merci à
tous les deux merci à vous bertrand
legrand médecin généraliste à tourcoing
merci à vous charles veut être président
mais de la carte française d'avoir
décrypter avec nous la dernière prise de
parole de olivier ferrand et de bruno le
maire